so we're in Chapter two you know I
believe you've looked us on the early
questions in chapter 2 and so and also
some of the fumes that are there so I'm
going to review them briefly and then
we're going to dig into two of the
harder questions that kind of pull
together all of these ideas and
principles one of which is this one okay
so first just so the seed is kind of
sodium line um have a look at this guy
right pretty standard like this whole
chapter is all about very simple kinds
of shapes um you could in geometry is
beautiful because all you need is a you
don't even need a rule up you need a
straight edge which bathroom you could
say it was a big deal that even without
actually measuring things and knowing
that the actual the actual legs that
things are all you have is a straight
edge you've got enough geometry here in
enough relationships that you can work
out how things relate to each other so
with just a straight edge and if you
wanted to we don't need one today um a
compass you can know a heck of a lot
about something and be able to
understand a very comprehensively so
within this triangle right you can see
they popped in these extra constructions
and then they give you some ratios and a
single measurement and you get these two
ratios here so this length to this
length one before but this length of
this link so that's these two sides over
here to three and then they just give
you the whole area of the triangle okay
they asked us for these last pieces down
the bottom they want this pink triangle
down here that I've colored and then
they want to work out how do these these
two sort of well they're not really
dialed but how these intervals going
across cutting across the triangle how
do these things relate to each other we
call these intercepts interceptors a
funny word because we use it to meet
lots of different things in mathematics
but it is context where you've got
intervals that cut across each other um
these are called the intercepts on these
intervals so what are the ratios between
them now the keys that we don't need to
measure any of these things you don't
need to measure
any um I mean as an example how do we
usually work out here betrayal we
usually do it well at the moment we only
really have one mechanism which is base
times height on to so you'd need to know
what this length AC is and need to know
is perpendicular high or I suppose you
could define anything as the base and
therefore get the car smoking
perpendicular height but the point is
you need to know some lengths you will
learn pretty soon enough um remind me
have you met much trigonometry earth yes
yes you have okay so you will learn
pretty soon that one other important way
for working out the area of triangle is
using terminology if you have no base
and perpendicular height correspond to
it it's equivalent to have two sides but
included angle you know what those are
like for example if you knew what that
ax was let CX and if you do what this
angle a XC was you can use this and you
could find out the area okay but kind of
the whole point of this is that this can
vary about that this is it's going to be
a different set of shapes and it might
have a different set of animals or a
different life down here in proportion
of these two so how do I work this out
this area without knowing any of those
things okay all i have is these ratios
so i want you to have this sort of
settling in your mind we're going to
draw this diagram and we're going to
work with it for as is less than
progresses but the window and you can
make that heading if you like our mom
parallels we're going to be drawing a
whole bunch of diagrams and working out
how to relay different areas and legs
together when all you have is ratios
between them so I've got let me count
one two three four four little sort of
theorems or properties for you and again
I'm gonna blow to them fairly quickly
because I know you've seen the early
ones before so this is more just uh okay
have it in your mind so that it's sort
of like fresh as you go through the
challenging questions for little
properties and i'll give you the way
stretch but the most important things
the diagrams that you draw with each of
them okay so let's see the first two as
a
hair because they kind of fit together
would you draw for me please for each of
these two properties I'm about to show
you a pair our panel lines and I would
just also know if you have colors here
if you have colors like color pencils or
highlighters or color pens or anything
like that they'll be enormous and you
still get them out as many colors as you
possibly can in geometry geometry is so
much a problem of vision right if you
can see a question properly if you can
see through the maze of wires to what
really matters then you can all often
solve the question very very quickly
okay so I'm going to use quite a few
colors in today so like I said for these
two properties you'll need a couple of
parallel lines for each right probably
number one if you've got a pair of color
lines and you create a set of triangles
between those parallel line triangles
like this
you
okay so if you have a look at this rate
what I've got is a set of triangles that
are balloted between these parallel
lines but importantly importantly here
comes my first I'm color each of them
this is a often we fix that one each of
these train was it is not only between a
parallel lines but they also all share
the same base let me pop that in here
okay now because there are also between
the same set of parallel lines the
distance between parallel lines all the
way along like the distance from here to
here the perpendicular distance between
one pair of the line the top on it and
the bottom one is always the same every
single time okay if you like you want to
figure out this way I could construct a
set of rectangles all the way along here
they're all have the same height okay
now because if I did that between these
parallel lines always going to get that
shape for example if i put in the
perpendicular how to save this triangle
you can see because that line is
perpendicular between those two parallel
lines it's always going to be
perpendicular no matter where I move it
so for instance I can move over here and
it would still be perpendicular I could
move it inside here and still be
perpendicular okay now the reason why
I've drawn all three is because now it
kind of makes clear to you every one of
these triangles remember at the
beginning I'll ask you how do you work
out the area of a triangle right at the
moment you need two things you need our
base you can see these all have the same
base and you also need the perpendicular
height and these all have the same
perpendicular angle okay so here comes
the wedding of the property I'll say it
once and then I'll say it again slowly
so you can write it down if you like but
the important thing is the diagram
triangles on the same bass anglers on
the same base between parallel lines are
equal in area that's it it's not crazy
trying doesn't have the same base
between parallel lines have equal area
that's all that's there
and I kind of think the diagram says
that for you again they're all triangles
they all share that same green base down
there and because there between those
parallel lines that's what gives them
all the same perpendicular height so
therefore I've seen base same
perpendicular height equal in aerial
okay there's the first time now the
second idea is kind of like that but
just slightly twisted okay if I stay
between these parallel lines let's draw
a new pair of triangles them okay now I
like in our first case where you've got
triangles on the same base and between
the parallel lines so therefore they're
all the same they're all the same you
can clearly see these two triangles not
the same are they not the same and so
I'm going to color them a little bit
differently to indicate that so over
here I've got this skinny guy on the
left so let's do human bone and then off
on the right we have this one that's
slanted off choose a minute okay now in
this case because I'm still between
parallel lines even though these
triangles are very different there's
still one feature and I mentioned it in
the first property that these two
triangles share what's the property they
share the property guide very good
that's what those parallel lines are
doing for you right every single
triangle wherever you draw them like a
dog all the way over here save
everything okay so all it's different
between these two is their basis now if
I just like name these patients let's
call this length over here a and will
call the base of the other one very
originally that petitions always
for that kind of thing be okay if the
ratios of their bases are a to be
because the only other measurements that
is different is the puppet of your
height but that's equal in both cases
then here are the areas where all the
same hue areas are not the same but
they're in this ratio can you see that
so for example if I actually called the
puppet of your height of this H as we
often do okay what would the area of
this actual train will be put the blue
one yeah very good it's going to be on
the base which is a time's the hype on
to write so that would be that would be
this area over here i'll call this a one
this one over here a to every teen will
be the same except I have a different
base right it's going to be base times
height on to attend my bases times
called be okay now you can see here
whatever H is is just a positive number
this to hear of a positive number so
just like any other set of ratios this
area 12 area too i can simplify it yeah
i could multiply both of them by two i
could divide both of them by h and i
find that the areas are in the same
proportion as the basis does that make
sense so this is this particular case
where they have the same base so they
will have the same area I guess it'll be
a 2a which is one to one okay but here
because the bases are just a little bit
different and the height is the same the
area of the triangles those proportions
will match the areas of the lates